what kind of tactical ideas are
interesting and basic to understand that
once you understand
you uh you take early leaps in
Improvement yeah so it's things like
forks for example where you attack
two-piece at the same time discovered
attacks like checkmates and again
winning like a queen or other material
those are probably two most important
ones
um batteries or batteries and pins
things of things of that nature how many
how rich is the world of and by the way
discovered attacks are when you move a
piece and you you put a king in check to
win like a rook for example or other
material and forking pieces is when
you're attacking two pieces so obviously
the other person can't move two pieces
at a time they're gonna have to lose one
of them okay so how big is the world the
universe of forks and discovered attacks
like
um you know I I I I I myself know so
there's like Knights attacking like uh
um or like a rook and a bishop
um it's innumerable they're I mean but I
will say that I think that with chess
the more of these patterns you see the
quicker you catch them and that's how
you improve I think the the most is by
learning these basic tactical themes at
the beginner levels are you when you're
discovering those patterns are you
looking at the chessboard are you
looking at some like higher dimensional
representation of the the relative
position of the pieces you know so
basically something that's disjoint of
the particular absolute position of the
piece but like you're seeing patterns
like this kind of pattern but Elsewhere
on the board like yeah are you thinking
in patterns or in like absolute
positions of the pieces both I think
that at the higher levels you're always
thinking about like you're thinking
about the patterns on one side of the
board specifically but then also what
happens is you play more and more if
you're very strong wrong player you will
be able to remember say Pawn structures
where the pawns are on certain squares
from games you've played like 15 20
years ago even potentially so it's a mix
I think a lot of it is more subconscious
than actively thinking about and like
figuring it out like that um the only
thing for me that I definitely am doing
very frequently when I play is is trying
to look at my pieces are they placed on
the optimal squares are there better
squares and then once I get past that
like using the basic logic I start to
think about okay what pure calculations
like what are the moves that make a lot
of sense and start calculating direct
moves but one of the most basic things
that I think that I do that a lot of
people actually should do that they
don't do is looking at the peace
placement trying to figure out what
pieces look like they're on good squares
versus bad squares
so am I for each piece asking a question
am I in my happy place am I am I like
optimally happy place I think it's very
important like if we look at this
position on the board right now as a
good example who's not in their happy
place on the board right now I think
both both sides are actually pretty
happy right now but the thing is if
you're playing with the black because
there's what is what is a move that
sticks out to you to like follow basic
principles
basic principles probably bring out the
bishop and then Castle the king and
Castle the King right exactly that's
correct and and that's what you should
do that's the best way to play the
position
um now once you do that by the way I
have a vibrating device inside you right
now so I knew that right and so my
ratings 3 400 which is what I believe
stockfish is higher it's like 3 800
actually is it 38 I think it is I'm
using an earlier version of stockfish
okay
anyway sorry you were saying so like
that's that's very basic but then if you
move the bishop out and you Castle the
king let's just say Bishop B7 play this
you Castle
okay so now you've done everything with
the piece on the king side so what would
be the next set of what's the next way
to try and develop the pieces
so it everything here is pretty strong
except maybe this Pawn I don't know okay
but think about the pieces so by pieces
I mean everything except the pawns Okay
I accept the pawns okay uh
probably
either either bishop or Knight right on
the other side yeah that and that is
correct you want to bring out the bishop
in the night let's say you go Bishop E6
yeah yeah all Castle now you can move
the Knight to either Square it's
somewhat irrelevant but just move the
Knight
I'll just play Knight to C6 oh what what
was your random move
okay oh well yeah what's your unhappy
place okay let me move the queen to just
follow some basic principles okay
because I want to bring my Rooks to the
center of the board yes so like in this
position you've pretty much developed
all your piece they're only two pieces
that you haven't brought into the game
the the queen and the Rock and The Rook
and this you consider to be in the game
because
um I wouldn't say it's it's in the game
but there isn't really a great Square
for that Rook right now
um but in this position you would
probably move your Rook to C8
and then the middle game begins after
that got it so here because now you've
gotten your piece to all the optimal
squares and now you have to look for a
specific plan but you have gotten these
pieces developed
um out of the opening and that's that's
like a very basic thing that I think a
lot of people don't think about is like
what are the optical placements for the
pieces so you're constantly thinking
about the pieces that are not in that
optimal placement as you're doing all
the other kind of tactics and stuff like
that but that's a basic thing that
people can follow actually doing pure
calculations like look moving five or
ten moves in your head that's not
realistic but trying to use basic logic
to figure out what pieces look what
pieces are on squares that look correct
it's something anybody can do what about
looking at the other person's pieces and
thinking about the optimal placement of
them like if you see a bunch of pieces
not in their optimal placement for the
opponent what does that tell you I mean
that's a higher level concept of course
that like I'm trying to give a beginner
example um that is something that I do
think about as well like I try to think
about my opponent's pieces like that
that is basic logic I think a lot of
people these days at the upper levels of
Chess they look at the game as something
of pure calculation and you lose that
human element you're trying to just
calculate all these different sequences
of moves and you don't think about the
the basics
um and it's something it'll be
interesting to see what happens with the
next generation of kids who become very
strong because that is really how they
approach the game they learn with
computers whereas like I learned with
computers at a certain point but I did
not start off with computers from the
get-go so human element still exists in
my game actually Magnus I think has said
this too where he did not use the
computer I think until he was maybe like
11 years old something something around
there and so we have that human element
to our game that I think the newer
generation won't have now it doesn't
mean they aren't going to be better than
us but it's going to be a completely
different approach what do you mean by
human elements just basic logic versus
Raw calculation so it's like anybody now
will use the computer from the time they
start the game and and you use the
computer you look at the evaluations
after the game to see how you're doing
but you if you don't really ever have
those moments where you're just it's you
or it's just you and your opponent one
thing that was great in the old days
before computers simply became too
strong is that you would actually do
analysis with your opponent after the
game and that's very much this two
humans analyzing game it's you and your
opponent two peers and you come up with
these human ideas it's not automatically
run back to your room look with a
computer on oh I should have played this
move and it's just like winning the game
so that is kind of something that has
that no longer exists um in the game of
chess because as I said there's no
reason to analyze with your opponent
after the game other ideas that the
engine tells you that you can't reverse
engineer with logic why that makes sense
and you start to just memorize it that's
good
um yes so in the opening for sure there
are certain positions where moves are
playable and I can even give you an
example actually in this night or if we
can just set the position up a few moves
earlier yeah night over I'm ba push one
see it
and just move the king back to the
center
and Bishop back to f8
and pawn to E7
so the pawn in front of the king just
push back two squares so
like here's an example there's a move
here that nowadays humans will play
which is this move Pawn to H4
um and this this is a move that 20 years
ago if someone showed this move to
Kasparov he would just laugh at them no
matter who you were he would basically
say you're an idiot what is this move
like you're pushing a Pawn on the edge
of the board it does nothing and this is
something that's it's playable but even
if you were to ask me or any other top
Grand Master why it's playable or why
it's why it's a move that makes sense we
wouldn't be able to say why it makes
sense because it doesn't we just know
that it's fine because the computer says
it's fine it's fine or is it good it's
just fine it can it probably like
everything else is equal with perfect
play but it definitely if you're not
careful with black you can be worse for
sure but if you ask me I can't say why
it's a good move I can say okay maybe
I'm gonna expand on the king side I'll
push this Pawn here and push the pawn
forward uh maybe maybe I can put the
bishop on G5 and in some positions the
pawn guards the bishop but I can't give
like an actual good explanation for why
it's a move that makes sense because it
doesn't make sense it's fascinating that
young people today kids these days would
probably do that move much more uh
nonchalantly you'll see that a lot more
because they know it's safe at least
right because I know the computer says
it's fine but I grew up without
computers and so to me as you're pushing
a Pawn on the edge it's the opening
phase you don't do things like this it's
just it looks ridiculous now of course I
have worked with computers long enough
that I know like I'm not I I know the
computers are um computers prove that
that everything is fine but still to me
it does feel wrong yeah well I think as
computers get better they'll also get
better at explaining which they
currently don't do at basically being
able to do
of so first of all simple language
generation so a set of chess moves to
language conversion explaining to us
dumb humans of why this is an
interesting tactical idea they currently
don't do that you're supposed to figure
that out yourself like why what's the
Deep wisdom in this particular Pawn
coming out in this kind of way